JENNY BROWN: Today we're talking
about sustainability, Spanner,
a compute GA, and live
Q&A. I'm Jenny Brown,
and welcome to
This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Google Cloud aims to
be carbon free by 2030.
We measure our progress along
this path with our carbon
free energy percentage,
which is now
public for the majority of
our Google Cloud regions.
We're sharing this data because
just like latency or cost,
we hope that carbon
emissions will
factor into your decision
making when moving to the Cloud.
Cloud Spanner recently launched
a point-in-time recovery
capability that
provides complete data
protection against inadvertent
deletion or updates
due to user error.
With this capability, Spanner
now offers continuous data
protection with the ability
to recover your past data
to a microsecond granularity.
This helps enterprises
quickly fix data corruption
to reduce risk,
loss of business,
and minimize impact on
customer experience.
We're excited to announce the
general availability of A2 VMs
based on the Nvidia
Ampere A1 tensor core
GPUs in Compute Engine.
This is going to enable
customers around the world
to run their Nvidia
CUDA-enabled ML and HPC
scale-out and scale-up workloads
more efficiently and at a lower
cost.
Check out the post
for a full rundown
of how our A2 VMs stand apart.
Did you miss the first
Ask Google Cloud?
Catch up with the recording
of the live Q&A session
all about serverless
architectures,
and don't forget to submit
your questions on Twitter
and YouTube with the hashtag
#askGoogleCloud to be featured
on a future session.
Stay tuned for more details.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.